Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Metrolinks and Crosslinks are reminding everyone to be careful, as Eglinton Crosstown LRT train testing is in progress. Please be alert, as trains can pass at any time on the tracks. Remember to follow all traffic signals. Be careful along our tracks and only make left turns where it's safe to do so.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。Metrolinks 和 Crosslinks 提醒大家注意安全，埃格林顿跨城轻轨（Eglinton Crosstown LRT）列车测试正在进行中。请保持警惕，因为列车随时可能在轨道上通过。请务必遵守所有交通信号。在轨道沿线请小心谨慎，仅在安全的情况下进行左转。
Be alert, be aware, and stay safe. Whether in the game or in life, the right coverage can make all the difference. Securian Canada gives you that coverage. For more than 65 years, Securian Canada has been helping Canadians build secure tomorrows. Their insurance solutions are designed to help protect you and your loved ones financially, giving you the peace of mind to focus on what truly matters.
请保持警惕，提高意识，注意安全。无论是在比赛中还是在生活中，合适的保障都能带来截然不同的结果。Securian Canada 为您提供这种保障。65 年多来，Securian Canada 一直致力于帮助加拿大人构建安全的未来。他们的保险解决方案旨在从经济上保护您和您的亲人，让您能够安心专注于真正重要的事情。
Find their products through banks, credit unions and associations, or visit SecurianCanada.ca. Securian Canada, insurance designed for life. We want to be a peace-loving people, but at the same time, courageous. That is why you must be peaceful and courageous at the same time. We want our people to be honour-loving. To that end, you must, from earliest childhood, learn the conception of honor. We want to be a proud people, and you must be proud.
您可以通过银行、信用合作社和协会找到他们的产品，或访问 SecurianCanada.ca。Securian Canada，为生活而设计的保险。我们希望成为一个热爱和平的民族，但同时也要勇敢。这就是为什么你们必须既和平又勇敢。我们希望我们的人民热爱荣誉。为此，你们必须从童年起就学习荣誉的概念。我们希望成为一个自豪的民族，而你们必须感到自豪。
Proud to be the youthful members of the greatest nation. We want an obedient people, and you must learn to practice obedience. We want a people that is not soft but hard as flint, and we want you from early youth to learn to overcome hardships and privations. There must be no classes or class distinctions among our people, and you must never let the idea of class distinctions take root among you. All we expect of the Germany of the future, we expect of you, we shall pass on. But Germany will live in you. So that, Tom, was very much not a friend of the rest of history, Fuhrer and Reich Chancellor Adolf Hitler, on the afternoon of the 8th of September 1934,
为成为伟大民族的年轻一代而自豪。我们希望人民服从，而你们必须学会实践服从。我们希望人民不是软弱的，而是坚硬如燧石的，我们希望你们从幼年起就学会克服困难和匮乏。我们人民之间不应有阶级或阶级之分，你们绝不能让阶级之分的思想在你们中间扎根。我们对未来德国的所有期望，都寄托在你们身上，我们将传承下去。但德国将活在你们心中。所以，汤姆，那段话绝不是来自《历史的余味》的朋友，而是元首兼帝国总理阿道夫·希特勒，时间是 1934 年 9 月 8 日下午，
and he was addressing the youth formation, so both boys and girls, at the annual Nazi Party rally, which was held in the Bavarian city of Nuremberg. And we ended last time, didn't we, with the aftermath of the Light of the Long Knives, the apotheosis of the Hitler cult. We did.
他当时正在纽伦堡举行的纳粹党年度集会上向青年组织（包括男孩和女孩）发表讲话。我们上次结束时，谈到了“长刀之夜”的余波，也就是希特勒个人崇拜的巅峰，对吧？是的。
You didn't want me to give the game away and to use the words Nuremberg rally because you thought that would spoil the excitement and the tension and the cliffhanger. Yeah. But I think I can now reveal that you're going to be talking about the Nuremberg rally. Yeah, so you've done me that. But I think I can now reveal that you're going to be talking about the Nuremberg rally.
你不想让我剧透，也不想让我说出“纽伦堡集会”这个词，因为你觉得那会破坏兴奋感、紧张感和悬念。是的。但我认为现在我可以透露，你将要谈论的是纽伦堡集会。是的，你确实做到了。但我认为现在我可以透露，你将要谈论的是纽伦堡集会。
Yeah. So you've done me that. And also you have conveyed the electric magnetism and power of Hitler's oratory. The charisma. Spitalflect. The diabolical charisma. Yes, because we had a bit of a discussion about whether you should do it in the German accent, and I'm glad that you did. And also you did it with the hand actions. Yeah. So the way that you built up to a crescendo, very, very powerful.
是的。所以你做到了。而且你还传达了希特勒演讲中那种带电的磁性和力量。那种魅力。那种恶魔般的魅力。是的，因为我们之前讨论过你是否应该用德国口音来表演，我很高兴你这么做了。而且你还配合了手势。是的。你那种层层递进直到高潮的方式，非常有力量。
Could we be cancelled for something the viewers can't see the listeners can't see no i don't think so because as you said i think it is important to convey to people the potency of hitler yeah as a national leader because if we don't understand that we don't get a handle on that if we just think he was evil full stop let's not think about it any further then you don't understand what is going to be happening over the course of the years that follow, which is essentially that Hitler and the Nazis set about, I mean, would it be too much of an exaggeration? Their aim is to brainwash the German people. That's exactly what they want to do, to indoctrinate them.
我们会被取消吗？因为观众看不到，听众也看不到。不，我不这么认为。因为正如你所说，我认为向人们传达希特勒作为国家领导人的影响力是很重要的。因为如果我们不理解这一点，如果我们只是简单地认为他是个彻头彻尾的恶魔，然后就不再深究，那么你就无法理解接下来几年会发生什么。本质上，希特勒和纳粹着手——这算夸张吗？他们的目标是对德国人民进行洗脑。这正是他们想做的，对他们进行灌输。
And in a way, this extraordinary gathering of the Nazi party a couple of months after the Night of the Long Knives and three weeks after the plebiscite that has seen Hitler become completely supreme, the Führer, the leader of the German people, this extraordinary public rally in Nuremberg. So officially, it's a party congress for the Nazis. It's not the first one. They've been having these congresses right the way from 1923. So the first one's held in Munich. They also had one in Weimar, but they also had a couple in Nuremberg. And the last one that they have is in 1929 in Nuremberg. And then they have it again in 1933. So that's after they've come to power and it's described as the day of victory. And I suppose in a way, the nearest equivalent would be the party congresses, the party conferences
从某种意义上说，这次在“长刀之夜”后几个月，以及希特勒通过全民公投成为至高无上的元首、德国人民的领袖三周后，在纽伦堡举行的这场非凡的纳粹党集会。官方称之为纳粹党代会。这并不是第一次。他们从 1923 年就开始举行这些大会了。第一次是在慕尼黑举行的。他们还在魏玛举行过一次，但也在纽伦堡举行过几次。最后一次是在 1929 年的纽伦堡。然后他们在 1933 年又举行了一次。那是他们掌权之后，被称为“胜利日”。我想在某种程度上，最接近的等价物应该是党代会，即党内会议，
that we have in Britain or they have in most democratic countries. But this is designed to be overwhelming in a way that say a party conference with Keir Starmer or Rishi Sunak. The comparison with Sunak and Starmer's party conferences is an outlandish one, Tom. Right. And the third and fourth congresses in 1927 and 1929 had been held in Nuremberg. The 1933 one had been held in Nuremberg, and the 1934 one is as well. And the day before the 1933 congress had opened, Hitler had said, we're always going to hold it in Nuremberg from now on. Because Nuremberg has an immense kind of symbolic resonance for the Nazis. And it's suggested by one of the most sinister, I mean, you know, all the Nazis are sinister, but one of the most sinister of all the Nazis, which is Julius Streicher, who founded the
我们在英国或大多数民主国家都有的那种。但这旨在产生压倒性的效果，而基尔·斯塔默或里希·苏纳克的党代会则无法相比。汤姆，将苏纳克和斯塔默的党代会与此进行比较是很荒谬的。没错。1927 年和 1929 年的第三次和第四次大会是在纽伦堡举行的。1933 年的大会是在纽伦堡举行的，1934 年的也是。在 1933 年大会开幕的前一天，希特勒曾说，从现在起我们永远要在纽伦堡举行。因为纽伦堡对纳粹有一种巨大的象征意义。这是由最阴险的人之一——我是说，你知道，所有的纳粹分子都很阴险，但其中最阴险的之一，尤利乌斯·施特莱彻（Julius Streicher）所建议的，他创立了
Sturmtrooper, patron of Unity Mitford. And he'd grown up there and he suggested it to Hitler as a suitable location because it is the embodiment of kind of medieval Germany, a Germany that's been uncorrupted by modernity, by kind of sinister things like modernist architecture. So in the official Nazi paper, the Volkisch Observer, an editorial in 1927, when the Congress had come there, had praised it for its turrets, its mighty walls and towers, which give testimony of manly power and fighting spirit. But Tom, there's all kinds of significance, historic significance to Nuremberg, because Nuremberg was one of the most common locations for the old imperial diets of the kind of
《冲锋队员》（Sturmtrooper），是尤妮蒂·米特福德（Unity Mitford）的赞助人。他在那里长大，并向希特勒建议将其作为合适的地点，因为它是中世纪德国的化身，一个未被现代性、被现代主义建筑等阴险事物所腐蚀的德国。因此，在 1927 年大会在那里举行时，纳粹官方报纸《人民观察家报》（Volkisch Observer）的一篇社论曾称赞它拥有“炮塔、雄伟的城墙和塔楼，见证了男性的力量和战斗精神”。但是汤姆，纽伦堡有着各种各样的历史意义，因为纽伦堡是旧帝国议会最常见的地点之一，属于那种
Holy Roman Empire. Yeah, absolutely. I've been to Nuremberg. I've seen the Holy Roman Empire as kind of the regalia and stuff in the imperial castle. It's also the city of kind of guilds and burr graves and all these kinds of things, isn't it? But it's also famous for its history of antisemitism. So there had been pogroms in Nuremberg in the 13th and 14th centuries, I think.
神圣罗马帝国。是的，绝对是。我去过纽伦堡。我在帝国城堡里见过神圣罗马帝国的徽章之类的东西。它也是那种行会、城堡伯爵和所有这些东西的城市，不是吗？但它也以其反犹太主义的历史而闻名。我想，纽伦堡在 13 世纪和 14 世纪曾发生过大屠杀。
Its history is interwoven with the Nazi myth of Germany's past. Right. And someone before who got all this, of course, was Wagner. One of his great operas is set in Nuremberg, The Meister Singer, and Hitler is all over that. And so the Nazis, when they choose Nuremberg as their base, they are identifying themselves very, very deliberately with all this and with the past. And in the 1934 rally, they have a showroom in which they're making this absolutely explicit. So they have Martin Luther, he'd written a notoriously anti-Semitic pamphlet on the Jews and their lies. And they have a copy of this on display.
它的历史与纳粹关于德国过去的迷思交织在一起。没错。当然，之前有人完全理解这一点，那就是瓦格纳。他最伟大的歌剧之一《纽伦堡的名歌手》就是以纽伦堡为背景的，希特勒对此非常着迷。因此，当纳粹选择纽伦堡作为基地时，他们非常刻意地将自己与这一切以及过去联系起来。在 1934 年的集会上，他们有一个陈列室，在那里他们明确表达了这一点。他们展示了马丁·路德写的一本臭名昭著的反犹太小册子《关于犹太人及其谎言》。他们展出了这本小册子的副本。
And they also, of course, you mentioned that Nuremberg is the center for the first Reich, the original Reich, the First Empire. They have a copy of Charlemagne's Orb and Scepter and Crown. And this really, really matters. The fact that the Nazis are aligning themselves with the First Reich and also, of course, with the Second Reich, the Reich of the Kaiser. So all these kind of parades and displays, that's very, very Kaiser. But of course, we've talked about this before, that the Nazis, what's distinctive about them, it's not just that they look backwards, that they're atavistic,
当然，你提到纽伦堡是第一帝国（即最初的帝国）的中心。他们有查理曼大帝的宝球、权杖和皇冠的复制品。这非常非常重要。纳粹将自己与第一帝国以及第二帝国（凯撒的帝国）保持一致，这很重要。所以所有这些游行和展示，都非常有凯撒的风格。但当然，我们之前讨论过，纳粹的独特之处不仅在于他们向后看，在于他们是返祖的，
that they are drawing on the wellsprings of a kind of imagined German past, but also that they are absolutely cutting edge, that they're looking to the future, that they're the embodiment of the white heat of technology and everything like this. And so this is the context for a famous pronouncement that Hitler makes actually in his first speech at the 1934 rally. When looking back to what Röhm had been wanting, a permanent revolution in a kind of brown Trotskyite sense, Hitler says, no, we're not going to have that. There will not be another revolution in Germany. And then he makes this kind of resonant, symbolic phrase, in the next 1,000 years. Oh, the 1,000-year Reich. Yeah.
在于他们汲取了某种想象中的德国过去的源泉，而且他们还处于绝对的前沿，他们展望未来，他们是技术白热化的化身，诸如此类。这就是希特勒在 1934 年集会的第一次演讲中发表著名声明的背景。回顾罗姆（Röhm）所想要的——一种布朗托洛茨基主义意义上的永久革命，希特勒说，不，我们不会那样做。德国不会再有另一场革命。然后他说了这个响亮的、象征性的短语：“在未来的一千年里”。哦，千年帝国。是的。
So this is where the whole idea of a 1,000-year Reich coming, a Third Reich that will last for 1,000 years. And the 1934 Congress is called the Party Day of Unity. So there's an emphasis on the fact that all the upheavals, all the bloodshed that had characterized the previous months, these are now over. This, in turn, enables it also to serve as the party day of power, because with unity comes power. Even though the revolution has been brought to a close, that doesn't mean that the Nazis do not want to project themselves as the embodiment of urgency, of clamour, of aggression, because this is how they are going to enthuse and inspire and excite the German people. Yeah. So when you say the revolution has been brought to a close, because they've killed Ernst Ruhm and they've crushed the SA, who are now just, I mean, they're still there,
所以这就是“千年帝国”这一整个概念的由来，一个将持续一千年的第三帝国。1934 年的大会被称为“团结党日”。因此，重点在于过去几个月里所有的动荡、所有的流血事件现在都已经结束了。这反过来也使它能够作为“权力党日”，因为团结带来了权力。尽管革命已经结束，但这并不意味着纳粹不想将自己表现为紧迫感、喧嚣和侵略的化身，因为这就是他们将要激励、鼓舞和点燃德国人民的方式。是的。所以当你说是革命已经结束时，是因为他们杀死了恩斯特·罗姆（Ernst Röhm），粉碎了冲锋队（SA），他们现在只是——我是说，他们还在，
but they're a shadow of their former self. So the sense of disorder, they want to lose the disorder, but they want to maintain- Keep the drama. The energy, I guess. Yes. The sense of drama and excitement. And the Nuremberg rallies are the kind of climax for a whole series of festivals that the Nazis have begun instituting, really to try and replace the old Christian and also the kind of socialist festivals. So they have begun instituting really to try and replace the old Christian and also the kind of socialist festivals. So they have a festival on the 30th of January, which is the
但他们已是昔日影子的残余。所以那种混乱感，他们想要消除混乱，但他们想要保持——保持戏剧性。那种能量，我想。是的。那种戏剧性和兴奋感。纽伦堡集会是纳粹开始制度化的一系列节日的高潮，实际上是为了试图取代旧的基督教节日以及那种社会主义节日。所以他们开始制度化，实际上是为了试图取代旧的基督教节日以及那种社会主义节日。所以他们在 1 月 30 日有一个节日，那是
day that the Nazis seize power, 20th of April, Hitler's birthday, summer solstice, which is kind of enshrined as a great pagan ceremony, all this kind of thing. But the Nuremberg rally is seen as the climax of the year. It's seen as the official way it's phrased is that it's a consummation of the marriage between the party and the people. It's couched in very symbolic, very religious language. Hitler loves a kind of atavistic pagan ritual. At the Nuremberg rally, you have this kind of weird thing where he consecrates new party colors by touching them with one hand. And with his other one, he clasps the cloth of the Blutfahne, which was the blood banner, which had allegedly been drenched in the gore of Nazi martyrs in the Munich Putsch in 1923. So you can imagine the kind of the Wagnerian chords striking up and all that kind of stuff.
纳粹夺取政权的日子，4 月 20 日是希特勒的生日，夏至被奉为伟大的异教仪式，诸如此类。但纽伦堡集会被视为年度高潮。官方的说法是，它是党与人民之间婚姻的圆满。它使用了非常象征性、非常宗教的语言。希特勒热爱那种返祖的异教仪式。在纽伦堡集会上，有一种奇怪的事情，他通过用一只手触摸来祝圣新的党旗。另一只手则紧握着“血旗”（Blutfahne）的布料，据说这面旗帜在 1923 年慕尼黑政变中被纳粹烈士的鲜血浸透。所以你可以想象那种瓦格纳式的和弦响起，以及所有这些东西。
And how much of this, Tom, is orchestrated by Goebbels? Because Goebbels, of course, has a PhD in kind of theatre studies or something, doesn't he? Goebbels is all over this, but Hitler is as well, because Hitler is a frustrated artist, Goebbels also. Yes, of course. And so they have this huge stage on which they can parade these incredible, well, I mean, literally Wagnerian dramas. Well, I was about to say, you mentioned Wagner.
汤姆，这一切有多少是由戈培尔策划的？因为戈培尔当然拥有戏剧研究之类的博士学位，不是吗？戈培尔对此非常投入，但希特勒也是，因为希特勒是一个受挫的艺术家，戈培尔也是。是的，当然。所以他们有一个巨大的舞台，可以在上面展示这些令人难以置信的、字面意义上的瓦格纳式戏剧。嗯，我正要说，你提到了瓦格纳。
I mean, Hitler's great hobby when he was a young man was going to see Wagner's operas with these very sort of lavish, you know, famously the Ring Cycle when people stage it, it's very over the top. Yeah. And so he must be drawing on that to some degree. But also, of course, they have huge casts. You know, Wagnerian operas require enormous numbers of people. But Hitler now, you know, he can command everyone in the Nazi party.
我的意思是，希特勒年轻时最大的爱好就是去看瓦格纳的歌剧，这些歌剧非常奢华，你知道，著名的《指环》系列在舞台上演出时，非常夸张。是的。所以他一定在某种程度上借鉴了这一点。但当然，他们也有庞大的演员阵容。你知道，瓦格纳的歌剧需要大量的人。但希特勒现在，你知道，他可以指挥纳粹党里的每一个人。
So as well as all the speeches and the exhibitions that they have at the rally, they also have stupefying parades. So there are about 700,000 people who are taking part, who are participating in this. They have a parade of workers. They kind of march through the streets. They've got shovels on their shoulder and they look tanned. They look fit. They're the embodimenthrer, of the leader. And they have a great rally of party apparatchiks, so Gauleiters, party district leaders and party members. Hitler are both incredibly alert to this. This is staged so that Hitler is able to address them as the sun sets. And it's timed so that his closing remarks coincide with the onset of night, the sun has set. And as he gives the last words of his address, they light bonfires along the horizon and great searchlights. They start kind of sweeping the sky so that it gives the illusion that he's standing in a kind of an incredibly austere and colossal Greek temple fashioned out of light. And so the impact is absolutely visually overwhelming. And I think
所以除了集会上的所有演讲和展览外，他们还有令人目瞪口呆的游行。大约有 70 万人参与其中。他们有工人游行。他们肩扛铁锹走过街道，看起来晒得很黑。他们看起来很健康。他们是元首（Führer）的化身。他们还有一场党内官僚的集会，即大区长官（Gauleiters）、党区领导人和党员。希特勒对此都非常警觉。这是精心策划的，以便希特勒能在日落时分向他们发表讲话。时间安排得恰到好处，使他的结束语与夜幕降临、太阳落山相吻合。当他发表讲话的最后几句话时，他们在地平线上点燃篝火，巨大的探照灯开始扫射天空，营造出一种幻觉，仿佛他站在一种由光构成的极其庄严、巨大的希腊神庙中。所以视觉上的冲击力绝对是压倒性的。我想
that for those who attend it, you kind of feel dissolved into the totality of everyone who's taking part. You're dissolved basically into the tattoo of the Volk, the idea of the German people, which is also a kind of German bloodline. This is what it's all designed to conjure. All distinctions are raised, as you said in that opening speech. No class distinctions. You're just all part of this great collective regimented mass. But a regimented mass that is being encouraged to feel at a kind of fever pitch of excitement, of fanaticism. So under the Nazis, the word fanaticism comes to be a word of phrase, blind obedience, which to us, I guess, would be a pejorative. To the Nazis, blind obedience is something to be celebrated. Nuremberg is the visualization, I guess,
对于那些参加的人来说，你会感到自己融入了所有参与者的整体之中。你基本上融入了“人民”（Volk）的纹身中，即德国人民的概念，这也是一种德国血统。这就是这一切旨在唤起的东西。正如你在开场白中所说，所有的区别都被消除了。没有阶级之分。你们都只是这个伟大的集体、纪律严明的群众的一部分。但这是一个被鼓励在一种狂热、狂热的兴奋中感受的纪律严明的群众。因此，在纳粹统治下，“狂热”这个词变成了一个短语，即“盲目服从”，这对我们来说可能是一个贬义词。对纳粹来说，盲目服从是值得庆祝的事情。纽伦堡是可视化，我想，
the dramatization of this kind of Newspeak, what Orwell would call Newspeak, the recalibration of language in the cause of the totalitarian state. Even foreign observers are overwhelmed and impressed by it. So there's an American journalist, isn't there? William Shira. Oh, yes. Who writes a lot about it. And he's there. And so he witnessed the parade of the guys with their shovels. I mean, I can't imagine anything less interesting than watching a load of guys with shovels walking past. But he's, I mean, he's all over it.
是这种“新话”（Newspeak）的戏剧化，奥威尔所说的“新话”，即为了极权主义国家而对语言进行的重新校准。甚至外国观察家也被它压倒和打动了。有一个美国记者，不是吗？威廉·夏伊勒（William Shirer）。哦，是的。他写了很多关于它的文章。他在那里。他目睹了那些扛着铁锹的人的游行。我的意思是，我无法想象还有什么比看一群扛着铁锹的人走过去更无聊的事情了。但他，我的意思是，他完全被吸引住了。
Long columns of bare-chested men standing perfectly at attention, then breaking into chants of ideological slogans and exhibiting extraordinary skill in goose-stepping, all to the spontaneous cheers of the spectators. So Schirer, I mean, despite himself, is impressed by this. He talks about Hitler as a messiah. People looking at Hitler like a messiah. And he talks about them being caught up in the mobs of people screaming and all that kind of thing. I mean, it's one of the most amazing descriptions actually of a Nuremberg rally you'll ever read. The ecstasy and the intensity of his description. Well, it's kind of like a rock concert or something.
长长的赤裸上身的男人队伍，完美地立正站着，然后爆发出意识形态口号的呼喊，并展示出非凡的鹅步技巧，所有这些都伴随着观众自发的欢呼。所以夏伊勒，尽管他自己也不情愿，还是被这震撼了。他谈到希特勒就像一个弥赛亚。人们看着希特勒就像看着弥赛亚。他谈到他们被困在尖叫的人群中，诸如此类。我的意思是，这是你读过的关于纽伦堡集会最令人惊叹的描述之一。他描述的狂喜和强度。嗯，这有点像摇滚音乐会之类的。
Exactly. Exactly. Because, you know, in due course, that is what the kind of the parade grounds will come to hold. Tom, do you know what? I watched a clip last night and I saw the screaming crowds. It was kind of digitally restored. So it looked less like 1940s footage or 1930s footage. More like Beatlemania or something. Exactly. Then a 1960s black and white footage. And I thought people at the time in Beatlemania did say, you know, cultural conservatives
完全正确。完全正确。因为，你知道，在适当的时候，这就是阅兵场最终将要容纳的东西。汤姆，你知道吗？我昨晚看了一个片段，我看到了尖叫的人群。它是经过数字修复的。所以它看起来不像 1940 年代或 1930 年代的镜头。更像是披头士狂热（Beatlemania）之类的。完全正确。而不是 1960 年代的黑白镜头。我想当时在披头士狂热时期，人们确实说过，你知道，文化保守派
said it's like the Nuremberg rallies. But this sheer ecstasy, the people sobbing with excitement. You definitely didn't see that when Stanley Baldwin addressed the conservative party in the 1930s. No, but again, it's proof of how the Nazis kind of forge a path that people, even after the war, will follow. So organisers of rock festivals, rallies, whatever, they are using the techniques that the Nazis deploy and are experimenting with. And it's a tremendous success. Now, of course, the challenge for the Nazis is how do they get the whole of the German people to share in this experience? Because Nuremberg is one tiny corner of Germany. How do you propagate it across the entire Reich?
说这就像纽伦堡集会。但这种纯粹的狂喜，人们因兴奋而啜泣。当斯坦利·鲍德温（Stanley Baldwin）在 1930 年代向保守党发表讲话时，你绝对看不到这一点。不，但这再次证明了纳粹是如何开辟了一条道路，即使在战后，人们也会追随。所以摇滚音乐节、集会等的组织者，他们正在使用纳粹部署和试验的技术。这是一个巨大的成功。当然，现在纳粹面临的挑战是，他们如何让全体德国人民分享这种体验？因为纽伦堡只是德国的一个小角落。你如何将其传播到整个帝国？
And the answer essentially is to send across that sense of kind of ritualized ecstasy to try and propagate it across every city, every town, every village in Germany. So that's why, for instance, swastikas are everywhere. I mean, this is kind of the default visual signifier for Nazi Germany, isn't it? And the swastika in 1934 is one of two flags. So you also have the kind of traditional imperial German flag. But in the following year, so the 1935 Nuremberg rally, Hitler announces that the swastika alone is going to be the German flag and it has to be saluted. And Schirra actually, in his account of the 1934 rally, describes how he has to keep ducking into side streets and so on, because he knows that if he doesn't salute the flag, the SA will beat him up. Yeah. And the salute that people are doing is the raised arm,
答案本质上是传播那种仪式化的狂喜感，试图将其传播到德国的每一个城市、每一个城镇、每一个村庄。这就是为什么，例如，万字旗无处不在。我的意思是，这是纳粹德国默认的视觉符号，不是吗？1934 年的万字旗是两面旗帜之一。所以你也有传统的德意志帝国旗帜。但在第二年，即 1935 年的纽伦堡集会上，希特勒宣布万字旗将成为唯一的德国国旗，并且必须向其致敬。夏伊勒在 1934 年集会的记述中描述了他不得不不断躲进小巷，因为他知道如果他不向旗帜致敬，冲锋队就会打他。是的。人们做的敬礼是举起手臂，
what they regard as a Roman style salute. Yeah. Have they inherited that from Mussolini? Is that right? Yeah, they have. So it's described by the historian Richard Grunberger, who wrote a brilliant book, A Social History of the Third Reich. And he describes it as being one of the most potent forms of totalitarian conditioning conceivable, because everybody has to do it. And so it becomes, unthinkingly, it's that kind of shaking hands or whatever. There isn't a law saying that you have to salute it, the swastika or whatever. But basically, if you don't, you'll get beaten up. Although Grunberger does point out, in fairness to the
他们认为是罗马式的敬礼。是的。他们是从墨索里尼那里继承来的吗？是这样吗？是的，他们继承了。所以历史学家理查德·格伦伯格（Richard Grunberger）描述了这一点，他写了一本出色的书《第三帝国的社会史》。他将其描述为可以想象的最有效的极权主义条件反射形式之一，因为每个人都必须这样做。所以它变得不假思索，就像握手之类的。没有法律规定你必须向万字旗致敬。但基本上，如果你不这样做，你就会被打。尽管格伦伯格确实指出，公平地说，
Nazis, that in 1933, it was agreed that dismissal notices issued by firms, especially at Christmas time, were not to end with the phrase, Heil Hitler. Because it couldn't be associated with bad news. Is that right? Yeah. So he kind of Scrooge, you know, kicking people out. He wouldn't have had to say it. So that's one way, I think, in which you do it. The swastikas, the Heil Hitlerling, the salutes, it just becomes kind of unthinking custom for people. But the other way in which you do it is that you invest in overt propaganda. So famously, one way in which specifically the 1934 Nuremberg rally is propagated around Germany and the world is that Hitler commissions a film to be made about it.
纳粹在 1933 年同意，公司发出的解雇通知，特别是在圣诞节期间，不应以“希特勒万岁”（Heil Hitler）这句话结尾。因为它不能与坏消息联系在一起。是这样吗？是的。所以他就像吝啬鬼，你知道，把人赶走。他不必说那句话。所以我想这是你做到这一点的一种方式。万字旗、希特勒万岁、敬礼，这对于人们来说只是变成了一种不假思索的习惯。但你做到这一点的另一种方式是投资于公开的宣传。所以众所周知，1934 年纽伦堡集会在德国和世界各地传播的一种方式是，希特勒委托拍摄了一部关于它的电影。
And the person he commissions is an actress who has developed to become a director called Leni Riefenstahl. And there is great mutual admiration between the two of them. So Hitler has been following her career with great interest. So she'd been a dancer, but there's this whole kind of weird craze for German films in the 20s featuring skiing and mountain slopes. And Leni Riefenstahl is blonde. So Hitler would call her the embodiment of German womanhood. And she ends up directing this film called The Blue Light, in which she plays a kind of noble peasant girl. And there's weird lighting effects and alpine snows and braids and all that kind of thing. And he absolutely loves it. And she likewise adores
他委托的人是一位后来成为导演的女演员，名叫莱妮·里芬斯塔尔（Leni Riefenstahl）。他们两人之间有很大的相互钦佩。希特勒一直非常关注她的职业生涯。她曾是一名舞者，但 20 年代有一种奇怪的德国电影热潮，以滑雪和山坡为特色。莱妮·里芬斯塔尔是金发碧眼的。所以希特勒会称她为德国女性气质的化身。她最终执导了一部名为《蓝光》（The Blue Light）的电影，她在其中扮演一个高贵的农村女孩。里面有奇怪的灯光效果、高山积雪、辫子之类的东西。他非常喜欢它。她同样崇拜
him. So she had first heard him speak in 1932. And in her diary, she describes it in kind of rapturous, kind of mystical terms. She's kind of blown away. So she does see him as a kind of messiah, do you think? I think she does. I mean, it's very controversial because, of course, she survives the war. And the question of her role, how embroiled she is in Nazi ideology is very controversial, but I think it's pretty clear that she is a true believer. And she produces this film, Triumph of the Will, which is kind of absolutely classic work of Nazi propaganda and a true reflection of what the Nuremberg rallies are all about.
他。所以她第一次听到他演讲是在 1932 年。在她的日记中，她用一种狂喜的、神秘的词汇描述了它。她被震撼了。所以你认为她确实把他看作某种弥赛亚吗？我想她是。我的意思是，这非常有争议，因为当然，她在大战中幸存了下来。关于她的角色、她卷入纳粹意识形态的程度，非常有争议，但我认为很清楚她是一个真正的信徒。她制作了这部电影《意志的胜利》（Triumph of the Will），这是纳粹宣传的绝对经典之作，也是纽伦堡集会意义的真实反映。
Because you watch it and you feel, yeah, this is simultaneously full of marching armies and torches and Greek columns rising up with beams of light. So it feels simultaneously very, very atavistic and very, very futuristic. I guess the sequence that most potently and notoriously expresses that is the opening. It begins with Hitler's plane flying over steeply banked clouds, and you hear the drone of it going and he he's kind of like odin who flew through the skies at the head of the great hunt but of course he is also at the cutting edge of technology he was the first politician to use planes to go around you know when he was campaigning when he was electioneering just on triumph of the will for those people who haven't seen it
因为你看它时会感到，是的，这同时充满了行进的军队、火炬和升起的希腊柱子，伴随着光束。所以它感觉既非常返祖，又非常具有未来感。我想最有力、最臭名昭著地表达这一点的序列是开场。它以希特勒的飞机飞过陡峭的云层开始，你听到它嗡嗡作响的声音，他就像奥丁，率领着大狩猎飞过天空，但当然他也处于技术的最前沿，他是第一个在竞选时使用飞机到处飞的政治家。关于《意志的胜利》，对于那些没看过的人来说，
it's a strange film to watch because of course course, it's evil. You know, we would regard it as evil, celebrating evil. But it is an absolutely brilliant film. As a work of art, it is one of the three or four most influential films ever made. And actually, there's another scene at the end of the film, Tom. You can see it on YouTube.
这是一部很奇怪的电影，因为当然，它是邪恶的。你知道，我们会认为它是邪恶的，庆祝邪恶。但它是一部绝对出色的电影。作为艺术作品，它是史上最有影响力的三四部电影之一。实际上，电影结尾还有另一个场景，汤姆。你可以在 YouTube 上看到它。
It's Hitler flanked by Himmler from the SS and Lutzer, who is the new guy in charge of the SA. And they're walking through the serried ranks of the Stormtroopers to pay homage. I think they're placing wreaths at a First World War memorial. And that scene is the scene at the end of the first Star Wars film.
希特勒由来自党卫军的希姆莱和冲锋队的新负责人卢策（Lutzer）陪同。他们走过冲锋队的行列去致敬。我想他们是在一战纪念碑前敬献花圈。那个场景就是第一部《星球大战》电影结尾的场景。
Yeah. When Han, Luke and Chewie go to get their medals. Yeah. You know, the Star Wars scene is deliberately modelled on Triumph of the Wooden. Even though Triumph of the Wooden is a Nazi film, that's a brilliant reflection of its astonishing given to her. Her crew is 120 people strong. Stryker puts a house at their disposal and they are allowed to dress the cameramen up in kind of, you know, workers' outfits or SA uniforms or whatever so that they can be part of the parades and get kind of close-up shots there. And Hitler and the Nazi leadership absolutely love it.
是的。当汉、卢克和楚巴卡去领奖章时。你知道，《星球大战》的场景是故意模仿《意志的胜利》的。尽管《意志的胜利》是一部纳粹电影，但这是对她所获得的惊人成就的精彩反映。她的摄制组有 120 人。施特莱彻把一栋房子交给他们使用，他们被允许给摄影师穿上工装或冲锋队制服之类的，这样他们就可以成为游行队伍的一部分，并获得近距离拍摄的镜头。希特勒和纳粹领导层非常喜欢它。
And it's kind of Hitler's personal baby. You know, he adores films. Famously, he loved King Kong. He loved Laurel and Hardy. He loved, you know, Mickey Mouse. I mean, he loved every kind of film. Yeah. As Stalin liked films, actually. Why wouldn't they like films? Films are great, but also films are new and exciting and, you know, captivating to somebody in the 1930s. Yeah. And so Hitler recognises that film is a perfect way to win people over to National Socialism. And so actually, I mean, he says that without talking pictures and without radio as well, there can be no triumph of National Socialism.
这是希特勒个人的心血结晶。你知道，他热爱电影。众所周知，他喜欢《金刚》。他喜欢《劳莱与哈台》。他喜欢米老鼠。我的意思是，他喜欢各种电影。是的。斯大林也喜欢电影，实际上。他们为什么不喜欢电影呢？电影很棒，而且电影在 1930 年代对某人来说是新鲜、令人兴奋和迷人的。是的。所以希特勒认识到电影是赢得人们支持国家社会主义的完美方式。所以实际上，我的意思是，他说如果没有有声电影，没有广播，国家社会主义就不会取得胜利。
And so right from the beginning, the Nazis had understood the importance of seizing control of the cinema industry and anything that is capable of propagating their message. This is how Goebbels comes to get the power that he does. Barely a week after the federal election in March 1933, Hitler sets up a Reich Ministry of Public Enlightenment and Propaganda. Propaganda, we say at this point, is a value-neutral word. It doesn't have the negative connotations that it has for us. And Goebbels is put in charge of it.
所以从一开始，纳粹就理解了控制电影业以及任何能够传播他们信息的东西的重要性。这就是戈培尔获得他所拥有的权力的原因。在 1933 年 3 月联邦选举后仅仅一周，希特勒就成立了帝国公共启蒙和宣传部。我们现在所说的“宣传”，是一个价值中立的词。它没有我们现在所具有的负面含义。戈培尔被任命负责它。
And we mentioned in the previous episode, Goebbels is brilliant at this. I mean, he has a malign genius for it. And he absolutely sees it as his mission to forge the minds of the German people out of steel. So he has this comment, you know, we did not lose the war because our artillery gave out, but because the weapons of our mind didn't fire. And so his office, he has seized control of all filmmaking in the Third Reich, with the sole exception actually of Lenny Riefenstahl's films, because those are Hitler's babies. And he has challenges because basically
我们在上一集中提到过，戈培尔在这方面很出色。我的意思是，他有一种邪恶的天才。他绝对认为他的使命是用钢铁锻造德国人民的思想。所以他有这样的评论，你知道，我们输掉战争不是因为我们的火炮耗尽了，而是因为我们思想的武器没有开火。所以他的办公室，他已经控制了第三帝国所有的电影制作，实际上只有莱妮·里芬斯塔尔的电影除外，因为那是希特勒的心血结晶。他面临挑战，因为基本上
a lot of the directing and acting talent has fled Germany. So Marlena Dietrich would be the kind of the famous example, Peter Law, Fritz Lang, all of these have gone. And also of course, there is a risk that you shove too much propaganda down people's throats. So to begin with, the films are very overtly propagandistic and people don't like it. And Goebbels is smart enough to realize this, that it's much easier to kind of, you know, a spoonful of sugar helps the medicine go down, that you smuggle in the messages and they do that quite effectively. And the Nazi film industry isn't full of kind of stormtroopers. Triumph of the Will is an exception. Most of it is actually escapist
许多导演和表演人才已经逃离了德国。所以玛琳·黛德丽（Marlene Dietrich）会是一个著名的例子，彼得·洛（Peter Lorre）、弗里茨·朗（Fritz Lang），所有这些人都走了。而且当然，你把太多的宣传塞进人们的喉咙里是有风险的。所以起初，电影是非常公开的宣传，人们不喜欢它。戈培尔足够聪明，意识到了这一点，即“一勺糖有助于药下咽”，他们把信息偷偷塞进去，他们做得相当有效。纳粹电影业并不全是冲锋队员。《意志的胜利》是个例外。大部分实际上是逃避现实的
schlop designed to keep people happy, but Nazi messages are woven in through it. You have the same policy with radio, which is really fundamental to how the Nazis aim to brainwash the German people. Where again, to begin with, when the Nazis seize power, there's lots of elevated, lots of Wagner, lots of Beethoven. And again, they kind of realise people don't really want that. And this matters because radio enables Hitler to address people directly. And so the requirement for that is that everyone basically has to have access to a radio. And so they do this in two ways. Goebbels deliberately commissions very cheap, very accessible radio sets. So there's one,
垃圾，旨在让人们保持快乐，但纳粹的信息被编织在其中。你在广播中也有同样的政策，这对于纳粹旨在洗脑德国人民的方式来说是根本性的。同样，起初，当纳粹夺取政权时，有很多高雅的音乐，很多瓦格纳，很多贝多芬。同样，他们意识到人们并不真正想要那个。这很重要，因为广播使希特勒能够直接向人们发表讲话。因此，对此的要求是每个人基本上都必须能够接触到收音机。所以他们通过两种方式做到这一点。戈培尔故意委托生产非常便宜、非常易用的收音机。所以有一个，
the Volkssimfanger, or People's Receiver, which went on sale in the summer of 1933. So right at the beginning of the Nazi period in power. And this has been compared in its impact to the iPod. Wow. You know, it's that seismic. It enables pretty much everyone to have access to radios. And this has been compared in its impact to the iPod. It's that seismic. It enables pretty much everyone to have access to radios. And this is a policy that will be continued throughout the 30s. And so a few years later, another even cheaper radio goes on the market. And this enables pretty much everyone who can afford it to get one. But even those who can't afford a radio, radios are put in offices, in factories, in restaurants, in cafes, in the stairwells of apartment blocks. So that's very
“人民接收器”（Volksempfänger），于 1933 年夏天开始销售。就在纳粹掌权时期的开始。这在影响上被比作 iPod。哇。你知道，它是如此震撼。它使几乎每个人都能接触到收音机。这在影响上被比作 iPod。它是如此震撼。它使几乎每个人都能接触到收音机。这是一项将在整个 30 年代持续下去的政策。几年后，另一款更便宜的收音机上市了。这使几乎每个买得起的人都能买到一个。但即使是那些买不起收音机的人，收音机也被放在办公室、工厂、餐馆、咖啡馆、公寓楼的楼梯间里。所以这非常
kind of 1984. Very nice. You know, Wynton Smith hearing Big Brother shout out. That's where Orwell is getting it from. And the result is that by 1939, the outbreak of the Second World War, there is no country in the world, and this includes Britain, it includes the United States, which is in so many ways, in terms of the media, much more technologically advanced. But in terms of radio coverage, no country has more radio coverage than Germany. And Goebbels is absolutely upfront about why this should be so. So this is what he said in 1933. We make no bones about the fact that the radio belongs to us and to no one else. And we will place the radio in the service of our
像《1984》。非常好。你知道，温斯顿·史密斯听到老大哥的喊声。这就是奥威尔从中得到灵感的地方。结果是，到 1939 年第二次世界大战爆发时，世界上没有任何国家，这包括英国，包括美国，在媒体方面，在技术上要先进得多。但在广播覆盖率方面，没有哪个国家的广播覆盖率比德国更高。戈培尔对为什么会这样非常坦率。所以这是他在 1933 年所说的。我们毫不掩饰这样一个事实，即广播属于我们，而不属于其他人。我们将把广播置于我们意识形态的服务之下，没有其他意识形态会在这里表达。所以它必须是纯粹的极权主义。它存在是为了锻造德国人的思想，就像德国人的身体也必须被锻造一样。好的。好的，汤姆，休息之后，为什么不告诉我们关于纳粹政权的另外几个方面呢？我想女性会是一个有趣的话题，因为我们还没有真正谈论过女性，也许还有体育，因为我知道作为一名精英运动员，你会喜欢谈论体育。我会喜欢那个。而且我认为更广泛地说，极权主义意味着生活的任何方面都不会被遗漏。所以电影、广播之类的，街道被纳粹主义统治，然后家庭也是。
ideology and no other ideology will find expression here. So it is to be purely totalitarian. It exists to forge the German mind as the German body also has to be forged. Okay. All right, Tom, after the break, why don't you tell us about a couple of other aspects of the Nazi regime? So I was thinking women would be an interesting topic because we haven't really talked much about women and maybe sports, because I know as an elite sportsman yourself, you would enjoy talking about sports. I would enjoy that. And I think more generally totalitarianism means that no aspect of life is left alone. So film, radio, whatever, the streets are dominated by Nazism, then the home also.
所以纳粹对女性、对儿童的政策，对于洗脑过程至关重要。好的。所以在下半场，我们将从阅兵场走进德国人的家庭中心。休息后见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、
And so Nazi policies for women, for children, crucially important for the process of brainwashing. Okay. So in the second half, we will move from the parade grounds into the heart of the German home. We'll see you after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news,
评论、一点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。我们认为女性干涉男人的世界，即他的主要领域，是不正确的。
reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. We do not consider it correct for the woman to interfere in the world of the man in his main sphere.
我们认为如果这两个世界保持独立是自然的。一个属于情感的力量，灵魂的力量。另一个属于愿景的力量、坚韧、决断力和行动的意愿。所以那是《历史的余味》的阿道夫·希特勒，他是在 1934 年 9 月 8 日的纽伦堡集会上发表讲话的，他是在对“妇女协会”（Frauenschaft），即纳粹党的妇女组织发表讲话。现在我猜情感的力量和灵魂的力量是女性，而愿景的力量和坚韧是男性，尽管我们很多女性听众可能会不同意。是的，所以希特勒非常相信那种性别
We consider it natural if these two worlds remain distinct. To the one belongs the strength of feeling, the strength of the soul. To the other belongs the strength of vision, of toughness,ness of decision and of the willingness to act so that was um foe of the rest is history adolf hitler again and he was speaking at the nuremberg rally in 1934 on the 8th of september and he was speaking to the fraunschaft the women's national socialist organization now i'm guessing the strength of feeling and the strength of the soul is women and the strength of vision and toughness is men though a lot of our female listeners may disagree yeah so hitler is very much a believer in the kind of gender
分工，不是吗，汤姆？他不是一个女权主义者，我想说这是公平的。我的意思是，没有一个纳粹领导人是女权主义者。有一本关于纳粹意识形态的入门书，出版于 1933 年，它非常明确地指出，德国的复兴是一场男性的事件。但仅仅因为纳粹国家的活动被视为男性的领域，这并不意味着纳粹认为女性的维度与他们是分开的。他们绝对保留了也去干涉那里的权利。当然，部分原因是，必须由女性为德意志帝国提供人力。但纳粹也认为女性的角色是抚养孩子。因此，女性需要被
divisions isn't he tom he's not a feminist i think it would be fair to say i mean none of the nazi leaders are feminists. There's a primer on Nazi ideology, it's published in 1933, and it states quite explicitly that the German resurrection is a male event. But just because activities of the Nazi state are seen as being the field of the masculine, this doesn't mean that the Nazis see the dimension of the feminine as being separate from them. They absolutely reserve the right to poke their noses into that as well. And part of the reason for that, of course, is that it is women who have to provide the German Reich with its manpower. But it is also seen by the Nazis as the role of women to bring up children. And so therefore, women need to be
分歧，不是吗？汤姆，他不是一个女权主义者，我想说这很公平，我的意思是，没有一个纳粹领导人是女权主义者。有一本关于纳粹意识形态的入门书，出版于1933年，书中明确指出德国的复兴是一场男性事件。但仅仅因为纳粹国家的活动被视为男性的领域，并不意味着纳粹认为女性的维度与他们是分离的。他们绝对保留插手这一领域的权利。当然，部分原因是女性必须为德意志帝国提供人力。但纳粹也认为抚养孩子是女性的角色。因此，女性需要
shaped in an appropriately Nazi way so that they can bring up good little Nazis. So this is the kind of thinking. There can be no private space. There can be no purely domestic space. Everything must be Nazified. A German's home is not his castle. I think it's fair to say. And although on occasion, the Nazis will say, as when say Hitler is speaking to women's organizations at Nuremberg rally, we're doing this for your own good. We think that you shouldn't have any political responsibility because that's better for you. You know, we're doing it for you.
以一种恰当的纳粹方式塑造，这样他们就能培养出优秀的纳粹小苗子。这就是这种思维方式。不存在私人空间，也不存在纯粹的家庭空间。一切都必须纳粹化。德国人的家不再是他的城堡。我想这样说很公平。尽管纳粹有时会说——比如希特勒在纽伦堡集会上对妇女组织讲话时——我们这样做是为了你们好。我们认为你们不应该承担任何政治责任，因为这对你们更好。你知道，我们是为你们着想。
Right. Aren't we kind? Aren't we kind? Yeah. Actually, it reflects a kind of dogma, which it's a dogma that sees the sexes as being unequal in a way that the Aryans and Jews are So Goebbels, who is a great one for the ladies, I think it's fair to say he's not the best looking example of Aryan manhood, but he's absolutely inveterate womanizer. And he has this extraordinary comment. He says, women has the task of being beautiful and bringing children into the world. And this is by no means
对。我们不是很仁慈吗？我们不是很仁慈吗？是啊。实际上，这反映了一种教条，这种教条认为性别是不平等的，就像雅利安人和犹太人是不平等的一样。戈培尔，他非常喜欢女士，我想说他并不是雅利安男子气概的最佳典范，但他绝对是个彻头彻尾的色鬼。他有这样一段非同寻常的评论。他说，女性的任务是变得美丽并把孩子带到这个世界上。这绝不是
as coarse and old-fashioned as one might think. The female bird preens herself for her mate and hatches her eggs for him. Not a chat-up line I would employ, Tom. Well, it's also, I mean, especially not to an ornithologist, because of course, one would immediately think of the peacock. No. Yeah. Okay. As a kind of a counter view to that. Yes. Yeah. And Volta Dare, who becomes the Nazi minister for agriculture and previously had
像人们想象的那样粗俗和过时。雌鸟为了配偶而梳理羽毛，并为他孵蛋。这不是我会用的搭讪台词，汤姆。嗯，这也是，我是说，尤其是对鸟类学家来说，因为当然，人们会立刻想到孔雀。不。是啊。好吧。作为一种反面观点。是的。是啊。而沃尔特·达雷，他后来成为了纳粹农业部长，之前曾
been a pig farmer, he attributed the desire for women to take part in politics, to have the vote, to have roles in government. He thought that this was the result of frustration set up by malfunctioning sex glands. Oh my word. So both Goebbels and Dare are following the science. In their own minds, at least. As they see it. Yeah. So obviously Goebbels and Darre are following the science. In their own minds, at least. As they see it. Yeah. So obviously they're not kind of downgrading women in the way that they downgrade Jews, but they do feel that science justifies them in confining women within the domestic sphere. And this had always been the case.
当过养猪户，他将女性想要参与政治、拥有投票权、在政府中担任职务的愿望，归因于性腺功能失调所导致的挫败感。天哪。所以戈培尔和达雷都在遵循科学。至少在他们自己的心目中是这样。正如他们所见。是啊。所以很明显，戈培尔和达雷并不是像贬低犹太人那样贬低女性，但他们确实认为科学证明了将女性限制在家庭领域是合理的。而且这种情况一直如此。
So right from the beginning, Nazi party ordinances had banned women from leadership positions in the party. And Hitler saw the fact that women in the Weimar Republic had the vote as being kind of absolutely expressive of everything that made parliamentary democracy corrupt and inefficient. Sort of feminized flabby, because they're part of that kind of we talked about this last time the sort of front generation yeah where the idea of kind of male camaraderie is so important to them and presumably yeah there must be an element in them being frankly slightly frightened of women would you say tom i don't know i don't know i mean the thing is that the nazis again as we have talked about they are simply amplifying traditions that are much, much more broadly rooted in a lot of German thinking. Deep-seated anxieties.
所以从一开始，纳粹党的条例就禁止女性在党内担任领导职务。希特勒认为，魏玛共和国的女性拥有投票权，这完全体现了导致议会民主制腐败和低效的一切因素。有点女性化、软弱无力，因为她们是那种——我们上次谈到过这个——那种“前线一代”的一部分，是啊，那种男性情谊对他们来说非常重要，而且大概是啊，他们肯定在某种程度上有点害怕女性，你会这么说吗，汤姆？我不知道，我不知道，我的意思是，问题在于纳粹，正如我们所谈到的，他们只是在放大那些在许多德国思想中根深蒂固的传统。根深蒂固的焦虑。
Yeah. So the famous slogan that everyone will think of, Kinder, Kuka, Kirche, children, the kitchen, the church. This is not a Nazi slogan. It's a slogan that goes back to the 1890s. It's kind of, you know, second Reich and everything. And so this is why I think there's quite a lot of support. You don't have to be a Nazi in Germany to think that this is an excellent policy. And when the Nazis kind of introduced natalist policies, in other words, encouraging women to have more children, they are doing what other countries are doing as well. So the French have been doing this since 1920. They've been offering medallions to women who have lots more children. They are doing what other countries are doing as well. The French have been
是啊。所以每个人都会想到的著名口号：孩子、厨房、教堂（Kinder, Küche, Kirche）。这不是纳粹的口号。这是一个可以追溯到19世纪90年代的口号。这有点像，你知道，第二帝国之类的。所以这就是为什么我认为有相当多的支持。在德国，你不必成为纳粹也会认为这是一项极好的政策。当纳粹引入那种“生育主义”政策时，换句话说，鼓励女性多生孩子，他们所做的也是其他国家正在做的事情。所以法国人从1920年就开始这样做了。他们一直向生了很多孩子的女性提供奖章。他们所做的也是其他国家正在做的事情。法国人从
doing this since 1920. They've been offering medallions to women who have lots of children. The Nazis, in that sense, are following the example of democratic France. They have this whole thing that if you marry, you get a loan of a thousand marks, and you have to pay it back unless you have children. The more children you have, the less you have to pay back. It ends up being calibrated in the way that it had been in France, that you get a bronze medal for so many children, a silver one for so many. And if you have 10, then you get a gold medal. And Hitler is godfather to your child, which means that if it's a boy, the boy then gets called Adolf. So that's nice. Golly. There's a lot of pressure then if you've got
1920年就开始这样做了。他们一直向生了很多孩子的女性提供奖章。从这个意义上说，纳粹是在效仿民主的法国。他们有这样一套东西：如果你结婚，你会得到一千马克的贷款，除非你生孩子，否则你必须偿还。你生的孩子越多，需要偿还的就越少。最终它的标准和法国一样，生多少孩子得一枚铜质奖章，生多少得一枚银质的。如果你生了10个，那么你就能得到一枚金质奖章。而且希特勒会成为你孩子的教父，这意味着如果是男孩，这个男孩就会被叫作阿道夫。那真是太好了。天哪。如果你有
nine kids, but you don't want a son called Adolf. Right. We hope it's a girl, I suppose. Adolfina. And you get this kind of cross, the cross of honor of the German mother, and everyone has to salute you in the streets. And it's very Spartan. This is what happened in Sparta, is that Spartan women could win glory for themselves by bearing lots of children. So in that sense, the Nazis are kind of going with the grain of policies that have been current both in Weimar and in other democratic countries. There is also, as well as the carrot of kind of medals and financial bribes, there is also however the stick. The Nazis are very keen to force women out of the workplace, partly for ideological reasons, but also because the big challenge, economic challenge they face is unemployment.
九个孩子，但你不想让儿子叫阿道夫，那压力就很大了。对。我想我们希望是个女孩。阿道芬娜。你会得到那种十字勋章，德国母亲十字勋章，每个人在街上都必须向你敬礼。这非常斯巴达。这就是斯巴达发生的事情，斯巴达女性可以通过生育大量孩子为自己赢得荣耀。所以从这个意义上说，纳粹是在顺应魏玛时期和其它民主国家当时流行的政策。除了奖章和经济贿赂的“胡萝卜”之外，还有“大棒”。纳粹非常热衷于强迫女性离开工作岗位，部分是出于意识形态原因，但也因为他们面临的巨大经济挑战是失业。
And so if you can get rid of women in the workplace, then that boosts employment for men. And again, this is a policy that had been current in Weimar, so it's not completely unknown, but it becomes increasingly coercive. So by 1936, for instance, it's forbidden to women to act as judges, as public prosecutors, essentially to have any position of authority within the legal profession. They're declared ineligible for jury service on the ground that they're too emotional. They lack logic. They lack the reason necessary. And they are also being denied educational opportunities. So in 1934, the same year that Leni Riefenstahl is making Triumph of the Will,
所以如果你能让女性离开工作岗位，那么就能促进男性的就业。同样，这也是魏玛时期流行的政策，所以这并不完全陌生，但它变得越来越具有强制性。例如，到1936年，女性被禁止担任法官、检察官，基本上被禁止在法律界担任任何有权威的职位。她们被宣布没有资格担任陪审员，理由是她们太情绪化。她们缺乏逻辑。她们缺乏必要的理性。她们还被剥夺了受教育的机会。所以1934年，也就是莱尼·里芬斯塔尔拍摄《意志的胜利》的那一年，
it's decreed that only 10% of students enrolled in grammar schools, which are the elite schools, can be girls. So 90% have to be boys. In 1937, girls will be banned from grammar schools altogether. Shockingly dominant. They're banned from learning Latin. In 1937, girls will be banned from grammar schools altogether. Shockingly dominant, they're banned from learning Latin. That is shocking, Tom. So some are enrolled in kind of courses that specialize in languages, but others are shunted into a kind of domestic science stream. And this is known as the pudding matrix.
法令规定，文法学校（即精英学校）录取的学生中，女生比例只能占10%。所以90%必须是男生。1937年，女孩将被完全禁止进入文法学校。令人震惊的统治地位。她们被禁止学习拉丁语。1937年，女孩将被完全禁止进入文法学校。令人震惊的统治地位，她们被禁止学习拉丁语。那太令人震惊了，汤姆。所以一些人被录取到专门学习语言的课程中，但其他人则被分流到家政流。这被称为“布丁矩阵”。
And it's a kind of absolute academic dead end. And so, you know, education is being used to essentially deny girls the education that their mothers had taken for granted so you get the resentment of people like so we did an episode many moons ago about the white rose movement and sophie shull yeah and of course somebody like sophie shull would be really chafing you know who's idealistic who likes reading poetry all that kind of thing And so there must have been a whole generation of bookish girls who were- Yeah, frustrated.
这是一种绝对的学术死胡同。所以，你知道，教育被用来从根本上剥夺女孩们她们母亲曾经认为理所当然的教育，所以你会得到像——我们很久以前做过一期关于白玫瑰运动和索菲·朔尔的节目——是啊，当然像索菲·朔尔这样的人会感到非常烦躁，你知道，她很有理想，喜欢读诗，诸如此类。所以肯定有一整代爱读书的女孩——是啊，感到沮丧。
Incredibly frustrated. Yeah. Or maybe they just took it for granted. I don't know. It's hard to say, isn't it? Yeah. I mean, certainly it reflects the fact that the Nazis entirely understand, you know, in the kind of Jesuit way, that to control education is to control the future of the people that you're educating. And the truth is, you've talked about the relish of students for book burning, students who are taking the lead in book burning. The Nazis can look at that, can look at the enthusiasm for the Nazi party in the elections. Again, in the episodes that we did
非常沮丧。是啊。或者也许她们只是认为这是理所当然的。我不知道。很难说，不是吗？是啊。我的意思是，这当然反映了一个事实，即纳粹完全明白，你知道，以那种耶稣会的方式，控制教育就是控制你所教育的人民的未来。事实是，你谈到了学生对焚书的热情，是学生在焚书运动中带头。纳粹可以看到这一点，可以看到选举中对纳粹党的热情。同样，在我们做的那些节目里，
last year, you gave the extraordinary stat that one in four people who voted for the Nazis in whatever it was, 1930, was a first-time voter. So I think that the Nazis can feel that when they're imposing their policies on education, they're kind of going with the grain of what young people themselves want. I think actually it's really important for people listening to this series who haven't listened to The Rise of the Nazis to get it into their heads. If you are young, the Nazis are very exciting and you think, brilliant, a break with the old men. You love the torchlight parades. You love the dynamism, the energy. The Nazis have a huge appeal to youth. This is not really an old men's party. It is a young man's party, isn't it, Tom? And to a degree, a young woman's as well,
去年，你给出了一个非同寻常的统计数据，即在1930年（无论哪一年）投票给纳粹的人中，每四个人里就有一个是首次投票者。所以我认为纳粹可以感觉到，当他们推行教育政策时，他们是在顺应年轻人自己的意愿。我认为，对于那些没有听过《纳粹的崛起》系列节目的听众来说，把这一点记在脑子里真的很重要。如果你很年轻，纳粹是非常令人兴奋的，你会想，太棒了，与那些老家伙决裂。你喜欢火炬游行。你喜欢那种活力、那种能量。纳粹对年轻人有巨大的吸引力。这真的不是一个老人的政党。这是一个年轻人的政党，不是吗，汤姆？在某种程度上，也是年轻女性的政党，
because the Nazis do give things for girls as well as boys. So what happens in 1933, we talked about this, is that anything that is not Nazi stamped gets dissolved, any kind of public organization. So Boy Scouts, Girl Guides, all those things get abolished. And so essentially there are now only Nazi youth organizations that you can join. And for boys, it's the Hitler Youth, and for girls, it's the German League of Maidens. And these are basically militarized versions of the Boy Scouts, of the Girl Guides. And Sophie Scholl loves it, didn't she? I mean, she really adored it, going out, comradeship, all that kind of thing. But I think it's also true to say that over the course of the 30s, certainly the Hitler youth becomes increasingly brutal. And Hitler in 1935 at the Nuremberg Rally, I mean, he's absolutely
因为纳粹不仅给男孩，也给女孩提供东西。所以1933年发生的事情，我们谈到过，就是任何没有打上纳粹烙印的东西都会被解散，任何形式的公共组织。所以童子军、女童军，所有这些东西都被取缔了。所以基本上现在只有你可以加入的纳粹青年组织。对于男孩，是希特勒青年团，对于女孩，是德国少女联盟。这些基本上是童子军和女童军的军事化版本。索菲·朔尔很喜欢它，不是吗？我的意思是，她真的很崇拜它，外出、同志情谊，所有这些事情。但我认为同样真实的是，在30年代的过程中，希特勒青年团肯定变得越来越残暴。1935年，希特勒在纽伦堡集会上，我的意思是，他绝对
explicit about the need to toughen young boys up in the way that the Spartans had toughened their young boys up. Terrifying. He says that this, we have undertaken to give the German people an education that begins already in youth and will never come to an end. It starts with a child and will end with the old fighter. So for a child's entire life, they will be essentially just a cog in the great machinery of the state. And what this means in practice for boys who are joining the Hitler youth is that there is relentless ideological indoctrination. They are taught to adore Hitler as a kind of god. They have military discipline instilled into them far more than they would ever have done in the
明确表示需要像斯巴达人磨练年轻男孩那样磨练年轻男孩。太可怕了。他说，我们已经承诺给予德国人民一种从青年时期就开始且永不结束的教育。它始于儿童，并将终结于老战士。所以对于一个孩子的一生来说，他们基本上只是国家这台大机器上的一个齿轮。对于加入希特勒青年团的男孩来说，这意味着无情的意识形态灌输。他们被教导要像崇拜神一样崇拜希特勒。他们被灌输了远超他们在
Boy Scouts. There's a lot of hazing that goes on both in the Hitler Youth and the League of Maidens. So boys will be made to go on very brutal kind of forced marches in kind of very skimpy clothes in the winter. So again, that's very, very kind of Spartan. I've subjected to very, very brutal punishments, kind of cold showers, all the works, kind of Gordonston cubed. And the girls also, I mean, so teenage girls, the Nazis don't approve of makeup. They don't approve of perms. If you have a perm, your hair is likely to be shaved off. To be fair, I don't really approve of perms. Right. But would you say you had a daughter and she wasn't wearing, you know, the kind of the
童子军中可能受到的军事纪律。希特勒青年团和少女联盟中都有很多欺凌行为。所以男孩们会被迫在冬天穿着非常单薄的衣服进行非常残酷的强行军。所以同样，这非常、非常斯巴达。我受到非常、非常残酷的惩罚，冷水澡，所有这些，就像戈登斯顿学校的加强版。女孩们也是，我的意思是，十几岁的女孩，纳粹不赞成化妆。他们不赞成烫发。如果你烫了发，你的头发很可能会被剃光。公平地说，我并不真的赞成烫发。对。但如果你有一个女儿，她没有戴那种
Gretchen kind of wreath of braids that was seen as being appropriate to a young German maiden? Would you approve of it being ceremoniously shaved off? Maybe you would. I'd probably be a bit frightened of it because parents were basically terrorized by their own children, weren't they? Because the children had been turned into kind of... Well, the children were being prepared for war.
被视为适合年轻德国少女的“格雷琴式”发辫花环，你会赞成它被仪式性地剃光吗？也许你会。我可能会对此感到有点害怕，因为父母基本上被他们自己的孩子恐吓了，不是吗？因为孩子们已经被变成了那种……嗯，孩子们正在为战争做准备。
They're being turned into future military officers. And so as a sort of weak and flabby middle-class sort of professional, I would just be utterly brutalized by my ruthless Hitler Youth honed, League of Maidens honed children, I imagine. Michael Burley, in his great book, The Third Reich, he talks about parents. Their children became strangers, contemptuous of monarchy or religion, and perpetually barking
他们正在被变成未来的军事军官。所以作为一个软弱无力的中产阶级专业人士，我想我会被我那被希特勒青年团磨练、被少女联盟磨练的孩子们彻底蹂躏。迈克尔·伯利在他那本伟大的著作《第三帝国》中谈到了父母。他们的孩子变成了陌生人，蔑视君主制或宗教，并且不断地像
and shouting like pint-sized Prussian sergeant majors. In sum, children appear to have become more brutal, fitter, and stupider than they were. Oh God. Yeah. I wouldn't want that. You wouldn't want that at all. And I think that that reflects a contempt for bookishness that comes from Hitler himself. So Hitler had been a failure at school, hadn't he? He'd been a kind of a dropout. Yeah. Lazy. And he sees a kind of over-obsession with book learning as not conducive to the forging of a master race. He's all about, well, he says, the breeding of absolutely healthy bodies, which isn't to say that the Nazis don't reform education. They do. And again,
小个子的普鲁士军士长一样咆哮和叫喊。总而言之，孩子们似乎变得比以前更残暴、更健康、更愚蠢了。天哪。是啊。我可不想要那样。你绝对不会想要那样。我认为这反映了希特勒本人对书呆子气的蔑视。所以希特勒在学校里是个失败者，不是吗？他是个辍学生。是啊。懒惰。他认为对书本知识的过度痴迷不利于锻造优等民族。他所关心的，嗯，他说，是培育绝对健康的身体，这并不是说纳粹不改革教育。他们确实改革了。而且同样，
interestingly with this, you kind of have the sense perhaps that teachers would be opposed to this, but they're not really. Teachers, as a profession, are very, very keen. Yeah, they are. As a body, by and large, they're quite in favour of it. I think because they're from that middle-class milieu that the Nazis had always appealed to. Yeah. You know, lower middle class. There's a particular kind of sinister idealism. I mean, to many teachers anyway, Tom, but teachers in 1930s Germany in particular.
有趣的是，你可能会觉得老师会反对这一点，但他们并没有真正反对。教师作为一个职业，非常、非常热衷。是啊，他们是。作为一个群体，总的来说，他们相当赞成。我认为是因为他们来自纳粹一直吸引的那种中产阶级环境。是啊。你知道，中下层阶级。有一种特别阴险的理想主义。我的意思是，对许多老师来说，无论如何，汤姆，但特别是20世纪30年代德国的老师。
Right. And so there is absolutely a sense that children need to be ideologically shaped, that they need to be conditioned by the controlling ideology that the state is decreeing they should imbibe. And so at the primary school level, they get rid of all the kind of biff and chip type reading books, I'm afraid to say. Dominic frowning at this. Well, that is poor. That is shocking. And they bring in loads of stories about German soldiers driving their bayonets into Russians and-
对。所以绝对有一种感觉，即孩子们需要从意识形态上进行塑造，他们需要被国家所规定的控制性意识形态所调节，他们应该吸收这些意识形态。所以在小学阶段，恐怕要说，他们摆脱了所有那种“比夫和奇普”式的阅读书籍。多米尼克对此皱起了眉头。嗯，那很糟糕。那太令人震惊了。他们引入了大量关于德国士兵将刺刀刺入俄罗斯人身体的故事，以及——
Yeah, Frenchmen. Stirring stories of Hitler's youth and things like that. They get rid of religion. So religious studies get phased out. And in their place, they use German history essentially to inculcate moral lessons. Crikey. Thank goodness something like that would never happen today, Tom. People using history as a branch of theology.
是啊，法国人。关于希特勒青年团的激动人心的故事等等。他们摆脱了宗教。所以宗教研究被逐步淘汰了。取而代之的是，他们基本上利用德国历史来灌输道德课程。哎呀。谢天谢地，今天永远不会发生这样的事情，汤姆。人们把历史当作神学的一个分支。
Absolutely. And also something that would never happen today in maths. So again, to quote Richard Grunberger in his Social History of the Third Reich, while mathematics teaching remained much as before, Nazi ideologists adroitly seized on the opportunity for subliminal conditioning presented by the wording of problems, so that a head for figures was now developed by questions about artillery trajectories, fighter-to-bomber ratios, and budget deficits accruing from the democratic pampering of hereditarily diseased families." Crikey. So you're getting maths questions that condition you. Nazi maths.
绝对是。而且在数学中也有些事情是今天永远不会发生的。所以再次引用理查德·格伦伯格在《第三帝国社会史》中的话，虽然数学教学保持不变，但纳粹意识形态家巧妙地抓住了问题措辞所提供的潜意识调节机会，因此，通过关于火炮弹道、战斗机与轰炸机比例以及因民主政体对遗传病家庭的娇惯而产生的预算赤字的问题，培养出了对数字的敏感度。哎呀。所以你得到的数学题是在调节你。纳粹数学。
And also in biology, there's nothing about sex because, don't talk about that. Although, Hitler youth leaders are instructed in the dreadful
而且在生物学中，没有任何关于性的内容，因为，别谈那个。虽然，希特勒青年团的领导人被教导了关于同性恋的可怕
consequences of homosexuality. Well, they want you to have a lot of sex within marriage to have all these children, but they don't want you to talk about it. No, because that's
后果。嗯，他们希望你在婚姻中进行大量的性生活以生下所有这些孩子，但他们不希望你谈论它。不，因为那是
kind of Weimar. And also, pupils in biology are trained to measure skulls and classify them according to racial types. So again, nothing like that ever goes on today in our leading museums. Thank goodness. Yeah. Yeah. But no, so that's all the bookish side, but the main focus is PE. So this is one of the many reasons why I'm glad that I didn't grow up in the third Reich. Yeah. You weren't a big PE person. I't a big person i hated pe i actually hated pe to be fair i mean this is kind of a podcast done by clearly two people who didn't like being yeah weedy bookish types who
魏玛式的。而且，生物学的学生被训练去测量头骨并根据种族类型对它们进行分类。所以同样，今天我们领先的博物馆里从来没有发生过这样的事情。谢天谢地。是啊。是啊。但没有，所以那是书本方面，但主要的重点是体育。所以这是我很高兴我没有在第三帝国长大的众多原因之一。是啊。你不是一个体育达人。我不是一个大人物，我讨厌体育，说实话，我真的讨厌体育。我的意思是，这基本上是一个由两个显然不喜欢体育的人做的播客，是啊，那种瘦弱的书呆子类型，
would not have been very valkish and uh this is the age of the pe teacher so never in history of pe teachers except perhaps in sparta, have PE teachers had more of a control. So basically they are running the schools. And there's even a proposal that they should all become deputy head teachers by default. Oh, that's a terrible idea. And so this idea that German youth should be made sporty, fit, healthy, that a premium should be set on physical activity. This is the context in which Germany is awarded the Olympic Games. The Olympic Games are due to be staged in 1936. So two years after his triumph in the summer of 1934, getting rid of the SA and Rome. Hitler had initially been
不会很“民族化”，呃，这是体育老师的时代，所以历史上从来没有，除了也许在斯巴达，体育老师拥有过更多的控制权。所以基本上是他们在管理学校。甚至有一个提议，他们应该默认成为副校长。哦，那是个糟糕的主意。所以这种认为德国青年应该变得运动、健康、强壮，应该重视体育活动的观点。这就是德国获得奥运会主办权的背景。奥运会定于1936年举行。所以在他1934年夏天取得胜利，除掉冲锋队和罗姆之后的两年。希特勒最初是
quite sceptical of it because he disliked the fact that it was organised by the International Olympic Committee because he didn't like the idea of an international organisation poking its nose into the affairs of the Reich. And also he kind of despised sport for its own sake. He despised the kind of English Corinthian ideal. So the games are about world peace, aren't they, and brotherhood and all. I mean, obviously often they're not. Yeah, it's all a bit wet. There is a sort of wet side to the Olympic Games that he would have no time for at all. And I think also the idea that as an athlete, you're only concerned with breaking records
相当怀疑的，因为他不喜欢它是由国际奥委会组织的事实，因为他不喜欢国际组织把鼻子伸进帝国事务的想法。而且他也因为体育本身而鄙视体育。他鄙视那种英国式的“科林斯理想”。所以奥运会是关于世界和平的，不是吗，还有兄弟情谊之类的。我的意思是，显然它们通常不是。是啊，这都有点虚伪。奥运会有一种虚伪的一面，他根本没时间理会。而且我认为，作为一名运动员，你只关心打破纪录，
rather than subordinating yourself to the entirety of a team. He sees that also as kind of ideologically dubious. He's not interested in sport, but he absolutely recognises, and Goebbels, of course, also recognises that it's a chance to showcase the Reich, to showcase German physical prowess, and to do on a world stage what the Nazis have been doing for the past three years in Nuremberg. And Hitler had actually, in 1933, he had expressed his hope that Nuremberg, he compares it to the Olympic Games, he hopes that Nuremberg will become the Olympic Games of Germany. And even though Nuremberg is a kind of the classically German city, that's why they hold it there. Hitler is fascinated by ancient Greece. He absolutely associates it with the kind of
而不是将自己从属于整个团队。他也认为这在意识形态上是可疑的。他对体育不感兴趣，但他绝对认识到，当然戈培尔也认识到，这是一个展示帝国、展示德国身体素质的机会，并在世界舞台上做纳粹过去三年在纽伦堡所做的事情。希特勒实际上在1933年表达了他的希望，纽伦堡，他将其与奥运会相提并论，他希望纽伦堡能成为德国的奥运会。尽管纽伦堡是那种典型的德国城市，这就是他们在那里举行集会的原因。希特勒对古希腊很着迷。他绝对将其与那种
primordial origins of Aryanism. He sees the ancient Greeks as being Aryan. And so the Olympic Games offer him the perfect opportunity to fuse classical traditions with Germanic traditions and to rebrand them both as Nazi. And so who are you going to call to propagate this message and to commemorate it and to send it out across the world? You're going to call Lenny. Oh, Lenny Riefenstahl. So Lenny Riefenstahl.
雅利安主义的原始起源联系起来。他认为古希腊人是雅利安人。所以奥运会为他提供了一个完美的契机，将古典传统与日耳曼传统融合在一起，并将它们重新包装为纳粹。所以你要找谁来传播这个信息，纪念它并把它传遍世界？你要找莱尼。哦，莱尼·里芬斯塔尔。所以莱尼·里芬斯塔尔。
But just before we get into Lenny Riefenstahl, I mean, we won't go massively into this, but he uses the Olympics, doesn't he, as a shop window. So they clean up anti-Semitic slogans, the SA are on their best behaviour, loads of foreign dignitaries arrive at the Olympics, and it is actually, for Hitler internationally, a colossal propaganda success.
但在我们进入莱尼·里芬斯塔尔之前，我的意思是，我们不会深入探讨这一点，但他确实利用奥运会作为橱窗，不是吗？所以他们清理了反犹太口号，冲锋队表现得最好，大量外国政要抵达奥运会，对于希特勒在国际上来说，这实际上是一次巨大的宣传成功。
It is, yeah. Lots of people come and they say, you know, the Nazis, maybe not everyone's cup of tea, but Germany is very clean and there's no disorder. And actually I didn't see any antisemitism at all. They handle all that very ruthlessly and cleverly. And so that's why Lenny Riefenstahl film Olympia is the perfect illustration of that. With Triumph of the Will, it's one of the very few cultural apogées of Nazi culture, and it's brilliantly done. Basically, it to this day serves as an inspiration for the way that sports is presented. It's a buried influence, but it's undoubtedly there. Riefenstahl has this brilliant opening where she sent a camera crew to Greece
确实，是啊。很多人来了，他们说，你知道，纳粹，也许不是每个人的菜，但德国非常干净，没有混乱。而且实际上我根本没有看到任何反犹太主义。他们非常无情且聪明地处理了所有这些。这就是为什么莱尼·里芬斯塔尔的电影《奥林匹亚》是完美的例证。与《意志的胜利》一起，它是纳粹文化中极少数的文化巅峰之一，而且制作得非常出色。基本上，直到今天，它仍然是体育呈现方式的灵感来源。这是一种隐蔽的影响，但它无疑存在。里芬斯塔尔有一个精彩的开场，她派了一个摄制组去希腊，
and they filmed the Acropolis, they filmed the Temple of Zeus at Olympia, lots of Greek statuary, which is all, you know, there's no nonsense about painting them. They're all very, very, very white. And then he has this famous shot where they shoot the statue of the Discobolos, the guy who's holding the discus, and it turns into a real figure who then unfurls himself and hurls the discus. And there's then a succession of nudes, so very homoerotic male nudes, and then female nudes. So these were not shot in Greece. They were shot on a beach in the Baltic because Riefenstahl felt that the footage she got from Greece needed spicing up.
他们拍摄了卫城，拍摄了奥林匹亚的宙斯神庙，大量的希腊雕像，这都是，你知道，没有关于给它们上色的废话。它们都非常、非常、非常白。然后他有一个著名的镜头，他们拍摄了《掷铁饼者》的雕像，那个拿着铁饼的人，他变成了一个真实的人物，然后舒展开来并掷出了铁饼。然后是一连串的裸体，非常同性恋色彩的男性裸体，然后是女性裸体。所以这些不是在希腊拍摄的。它们是在波罗的海的一个海滩上拍摄的，因为里芬斯塔尔觉得她在希腊得到的镜头需要加点料。
And so there's all kinds of nudity going on. And one of them is actually Lenny Riefenstahl herself. So there's a shot of a woman on a beach and she's got her arms extended to the heavens and that's Lenny herself. And then this sequence ends with a runner bringing the torch and he's running from Greece into the German stadium in Berlin. So it's Greece blurring and being succeeded by Germany. with a runner bringing the torch and he's running from Greece into the German stadium in Berlin. So it's Greece blurring and being succeeded by Germany. And part of the reason why this is so potent is that Olympia, for instance, it doesn't cut out from the Nazi perspective,
所以到处都是裸体。其中一个实际上是莱尼·里芬斯塔尔本人。所以有一个镜头是一个女人在海滩上，她双臂伸向天空，那就是莱尼本人。然后这个序列以一名火炬手结束，他从希腊跑进柏林的德国体育场。所以这是希腊模糊并被德国所取代。随着一名火炬手带来火炬，他从希腊跑进柏林的德国体育场。所以这是希腊模糊并被德国所取代。这之所以如此有效，部分原因是《奥林匹亚》，例如，它并没有从纳粹的角度剪掉，
racially problematic victors. So Jesse Owens, who is the black American athlete, who is the star of the Olympics, he's in the film. So also is Kite Son, who is from Korea, although he's racing under the flag of Imperial Japan, which has conquered Korea and wins the marathon. He's in it as well. And so this is part of why Olympia, the film, does hold up a mirror to the impact of the games as a whole. It gives a kind of sanitized take on the Nazi regime. And actually, it's a measure of how successful the Nazis are promoting their message that the Olympics have been a brilliant success, that actually it's been claimed that it has a kind of interplanetary impact.
种族上有问题的获胜者。所以杰西·欧文斯，那位黑人美国运动员，奥运会的明星，他在电影里。还有来自韩国的孙基祯，尽管他是在大日本帝国的旗帜下参赛（日本已经征服了韩国），并赢得了马拉松比赛。他也在里面。所以这就是为什么电影《奥林匹亚》确实为整个奥运会的影响提供了一面镜子。它对纳粹政权进行了某种美化。实际上，纳粹在推广他们的信息方面有多成功，奥运会是一个辉煌的成功，以至于有人声称它产生了一种行星际的影响。
Interplanetary, Tom. Interplanetary, because it's been claimed that the first television broadcast that was able to reach out beyond our atmosphere and out into outer space was the speech by Hitler with which he introduces the Olympic Games. So that'd be nice for aliens out there wondering what planet Earth is all about. Depressing thought. Yeah. However, there is a problem, which is that Olympia is broadcast on the 20th of April 1938, which is Hitler's 47th birthday. That's the premiere. That's the premiere. And so by the time it is premiered, any notion that Nazi Germany is not virulently anti-Semitic and is not dangerously militaristic is basically gone. And so that message actually falls on
行星际，汤姆。行星际，因为有人声称，第一个能够到达我们大气层之外并进入外太空的电视广播，就是希特勒介绍奥运会的演讲。所以这对那些想知道地球是什么样子的外星人来说会很不错。令人沮丧的想法。是啊。然而，有一个问题，那就是《奥林匹亚》是在1938年4月20日播出的，那是希特勒的47岁生日。那是首映式。那是首映式。所以当它首映时，任何认为纳粹德国不是恶毒的反犹太主义者且不是危险的军国主义者的想法基本上都消失了。所以那个信息实际上落在了
very soily ground. Because since 1936, a lot has changed in terms of Germany's international position. And Dominic, I think it would not be an exaggeration to say that the storm clouds of war are gathering over Europe. Would you be prepared to go that far? I think we do love a storm cloud of war and the rest Europe. Would you be prepared to go that far? I think we do love a storm cloud of war and the rest is history, Tom. We always have. And these are the storm clouds to end all storm clouds. It's a veritable tempest, a hurricane is coming for Europe. Right.
非常贫瘠的土地上。因为自1936年以来，德国的国际地位发生了很大变化。多米尼克，我认为说战争的乌云正在欧洲上空聚集并不夸张。你准备好走那么远了吗？我想我们确实喜欢战争的乌云，其余的欧洲。你准备好走那么远了吗？我想我们确实喜欢战争的乌云，剩下的就是历史了，汤姆。我们一直都这样。这些是终结所有乌云的乌云。这是一场真正的风暴，一场飓风即将来临欧洲。对。
Well, thank you, Tom. That was not merely a fantastic tour d'horizon. It was a veritable tour de force and next week we'll be digging more closely won't we into the nazis and their foreign policy because we'll be doing an episode about hitler his vision of war and his plans for war and then we'll be doing an episode specifically looking at hitler and the conquest of austria the anchelus and tom rest is history club members will be able to listen to those episodes right now won't they they absolutely will you know the routine restlesshistory.com you can sign up there but if you don't want to do that doesn't matter you can wait till next week you'll still get to hear them so thanks very much for listening and bye-bye bye-bye I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman
好吧，谢谢你，汤姆。这不仅仅是一次精彩的概览。这简直是一次真正的杰作，下周我们将更深入地挖掘，不是吗，关于纳粹和他们的外交政策，因为我们将做一期关于希特勒、他的战争愿景和战争计划的节目，然后我们将做一期专门审视希特勒和征服奥地利（德奥合并）的节目，汤姆，“其余就是历史”俱乐部的成员现在就能听到这些节目，不是吗？他们绝对可以，你知道流程，restlesshistory.com，你可以在那里注册，但如果你不想这样做也没关系，你可以等到下周，你仍然会听到它们，所以非常感谢你们的收听，再见，再见，我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，
and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain
我们一起主持《其余就是娱乐》，这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们拉开帷幕，
on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to
关于娱乐，我们告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往
therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。